[Music]
who or what created the zenom movs which
are undoubtedly the most famous and
well-known aliens from movies well we
know that HR Gyer designed them for the
first film that was directed by rley
Scott but if we're talking about fiction
and lore what is their real origin story
We are one of the biggest fans of these
creatures and as far as we know there
are different Genesis stories spread
across different continuities so let's
check them
out the first one Evolution on xenomorph
Prime so this is the lore behind the
original series of movies and the comics
according to a prevalent theory in the
alien expanded universe Xenomorphs are
believed to have originated on a distant
planet called xenomorph Prime the theory
suggest that these creatures evolved
over a long period of time adapting to
the harsh conditions of their Planet
through this process they developed the
distinctive biomechanic iCal features
which includes their hardened
exoskeletons their tubes and their long
bulbous head the Xenomorphs with their
unique and ferocious life cycle
eventually became the apex predators on
their home World by gradually
eliminating every other species however
as time weigh on there Rose different
zenom of hives across the planet and
there would frequently be battles and
Wars for dominance as depicted in Aliens
genocide but despite this endless
Warfare somehow a queen mother would
eventually take control of the entire
speci
and this shows that the Xenomorphs are a
prime example of hyper
Evolution the second one they were bred
by the Ancient draki Aliens this is
based on the low behind the Dark Horse
AP expanded universe and Comics so
little us know about them the daki
aliens which are enigmatic to say the
least nothing is known about them from
any planet or any structure which they
might have created or built the only
thing we know about them is that they
were a highly Advanced space fairing
civilization in the distant pause
according to the yya or better known as
the Predators the draki left the Milky
Way eons ago reloca to another galaxy
the yya despite their warlike nature
actually hate and fear them and these
ancient beings considering them Beyond
malevolent Beyond understanding so at
some point of time in the distant par
these daki aliens were thought to have
encountered the xenom of xx121 species
on xenom off Prime and then took
interest in the life form actively
engaging in breeding and experimenting
on this pie
to a point where the deadly
biomechanical monsters gradually became
the end product which scared them to a
point that they have to leave the
Galaxy number three they were created by
the engineers in the Prometheus film The
Mysterious Engineers Also earlier in the
alien franchise which were known as
space jockeys sparked speculation about
their connection to the Xenomorphs and
their Genesis according to theories
supported by Ridley Scott himself the
engineers may have engineered the zenom
mols as a bioweapon origin gentic
experiment which went haywire and caused
the deaths of all of them as seen in
glimpses of the deric ship's recordings
it is suggested these ancient alien
species intended the Xenomorphs for a
specific role or a purpose but lost
control resulting in the night marriage
consequences seen in the films these
theorist are supported by the fact that
the engineer ship carried the black goo
meant to be Unleashed on unsuspecting
worlds or almost specifically on Earth
and as was seen when David tested the
pathogen onto hallway which then was
passed on to Elizabeth shaww and then to
the engineer giving rise to a deacon
which was a form of a xenom molf also
the presence of a zenom Mo's mural
inside the engineer ship implies their
knowledge of their creation and hence
their involvement in planning or
creating the
creature number four they were
experimented or created by David in the
sequel to Prometheus which is alien
Covenant there was a refined creation
myth for the xenom mols at least the
ones that was familiar to us that looked
like the original aliens from the first
film in both the Prometheus and the
alien Covenant movies David the Android
is shown to be conducting experiments
with the genetic material from the black
goo on various species especially in the
second movie rdy Scott had recently
suggested a theory where David motivated
by a desire to create the perfect
organism to be like whan his creator
plays a significant role in the origin
of the xenom movs as in trying to create
his own legacy however according to
alien Covenant the novelization an
alternative explanation is proposed and
that is David might have just recreated
the factors needed to bring about the
xenomorph and this was based on the
original engineer plans that he
discovered on the planet the fifth
origin story they were created by a
xenom of goddess so this is actually the
newest origin story or a theory from the
Marvel continuity of the alien franchise
Marvel's New Alien series explores the
potential Galactic purpose for the
Xenomorphs as they were depicted as
ruthless clever and devoid of sympathy
or emotions seeking humans or seeing
them as just mere tools to propagate
their species according to the storyline
when organic species become ambitious
enough to venture into space the
Xenomorphs act as a galactic security
system eliminating them as a form of
Prometheus cleansing fire and behind all
of their species is a dreaded woman in
the dark portrayed as some sort of a
human xenom of hybrid a goddess amongst
their species which might have been the
one who created these deadly Cosmic
horror alien monsters and number six the
last origin story they were bred by the
Predators so this is a continuation of
the draki lore just as the engineers
were the first ones to create the
Xenomorphs and David the Android who
would then perfect upon that blueprint
you know in the Prometheus origin story
so is this the same for the origin tale
of the Xenomorphs regarding to the dakil
lore the Predators or also known as the
yaoya might have discovered the
Xenomorphs at some point of time during
the space travels in their rituals of
coming of age whereby young Bloods would
hunt and kill deadly alien creatures in
order to be granted the honor of joining
the clan as adults so these Predators
might have taken interest in the zenov
for their supremely deadly abilities and
bred them across countless worlds
continuing the legacy of the daki aliens
the same aliens which they hate so
dearly so in short the Xenomorphs were
created by different entities in
different continuities it is by the
predators in the AP franchise by either
David or the engine
in the new world Prometheus movies by
the daki aliens in the AP Comics or by a
goddess in Marvel or they might just
have evolved by themselves as in the
original story line and they would be
discovered by the other Advanced species
and maybe unknowingly or unintentionally
or maybe intentionally as well spread
across countless worlds across the
Galaxy now if you like this video then
watch this other one as well and do
check out our channel for other monster
content we might just have topics that
you haven't seen on heard before like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video take care
fam